bonjour rodrigo martinez parra merci de
répondre à nos questions une journée
d'hommage coup de com ou véritable de
reconnaissance bonjour bas depuis le
début de la crise on voit que ça a été
une gestion de la pénurie et que
finalement le gouvernement nous a
surtout fait des beaux effets de
communication notamment avec la promesse
du ségur et que nous sur le terrain pour
me vois pas du tout les aboutissements
il ya un an le personnel soignant était
systématiquement un peu dire par par les
français le fait d'appeler à une journée
d'hommage c'est parce que les blouses
blanches sans oublier maintenant on est
bien loin des applaudissements bien sûr
et le personnel est certainement plus
que fatigués moi j'ai de nombreux
collègues qui sont en berne à août
on peut comprendre que c'est cette
journée peut susciter l'intérêt de
certaines personnes pourquoi pas mais je
pense que c'est pas vraiment la priorité
à ce jour quelle est la priorité alors
un sondage de la fédération hospitalière
de france dévoile que seulement 12 % du
personnel hospitalier est totalement
satisfait de ses conditions de travail
comment est-ce que vous interprétez ce
chiffre c'est à dire que la journée
d'hommage au final c'est une façon de
mettre sur la table les problèmes du
système de santé français
malgré le ségur bah écoutez si c'est pas
tout de mettre les choses sur la table
il faut il encore être entendus avec le
collectif interrogeant ça fait deux ans
qu'on se bat pour interpeller justement
sur les conditions de travail et est la
prise en charge de l'orientation athlète
de 19 milliards d'euros pour l'hôpital
français jean castex en a dévoilé les
grandes lignes
récemment c'est qu'il y aurait eu
également également l'été dernier une
revalorisation à 283 euros pour pour le
personnel hospitalier
oui bien sûr les enveloppes seront sont
assez impressionnantes au niveau de
chiffre
quand on parle de milliards mais on
reste sur une politique de rentabilité
avec une vision des soins qui sont
vraiment d'un point de vue économique
à savoir que par exemple les urgences de
manière vexin dans le 95 sont menacés
d'être fermé donc on continue sur une
politique d'austérité où on veut fermer
les services et le moins de l'ordre
d'être à la rentabilité
qu'est ce que vous entendez qu'est ce
que vous attendez à l'ordre de la part
du gouvernement
tout simplement qu'on mette les moyens
déjà pour commencer on pourrait écouter
les soignants pour iphone est alors les
moyens ça veut dire en termes de
chiffres on vient de parler de 10,9
milliards d'euros pour le secteur de la
santé en tous les cas ce qui m'a remis
sur la table prochainement vous qu'on
vous dit on attend des moyens ça veut
dire combien déjà avoir les moyens
suffisants pour pouvoir continuer à
ouvrir des lits du moins arrêter les
fermetures de lits se fixer des
objectifs en fonction des besoins de la
population et pour ça il faut pouvoir
embaucher et revaloriser les salaires
comme il avait été demandé de 300 euros
parce que c'est ce qui a été perdu avec
le gel des indices depuis plus de dix
ans merci oui rapidement et puis des
mois vous savez aux urgences le turnover
est tel que maintenant on a des
soignants qui vont 6 mois 1 an
d'expérience et qui sont en train de
former les nouveaux arrivants mais les
gens ne reste plus dans le service
hospitalier ça m'intéresse plus merci le
message est passé
rodrigo martinez parra merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le vice-président du collectif
interurbain ans